- Everyone here is wearing overalls,
and nobody wants to fuck me.
Hi, I'm Kate!
And I am undateable in Los Angeles.
This sums up about 90%
of the messages I get
on dating apps while in LA.
I said a simple "sup" and he said,
fingering a grapefruit.
That's quite the leap.
Unwilling to even consider the possibility
that maybe it's me.
I figure somewhere in America
I've gotta be dateable.
And I'm gonna find that city.
We're going to rate each city
on the following criteria.
Number of matches,
overall price of the city,
and is it a fun place to be single in.
First up, San Francisco, the land of tech.
Tech land.
Land of the app.
My theory is that I will get
more matches in San Francisco.
And my hope is that even if I don't,
it's still a fun city to be single in.
Here in the airport, getting
ready to fly to San Francisco,
to hopefully, get some dates.
Open to all the possible rejections.
The second we landed in San Francisco,
I immediately started swiping.
- [Pilot] San Fransisco's
International Airport.
- I started swiping.
I started swiping right
on just about everybody,
except for people who
looked incredibly creepy.
I found that putting
exactly what I'm looking for
in my bio is helping me get
the matches that I wanted.
If you want a certain thing,
put it in your bio.
That's what it's for.
Looks good!
And then just let them come to you.
(gasps)
Did I figure out dating?
Am I gonna fucking fall in love right now?
Ooh, I'm getting a billion messages.
This guy.
Who we had a delightful conversation.
I was like, "Wow, this is gonna
be easier than I thought."
And then he goes, "What're
your thoughts on hung men?"
(laughs)
Listen, do what you wanna do.
I just, I felt weird.
You guys, you should get it.
(laughs)
While I was waiting for all of
the date results to come in,
I decided to go and ask some locals
what they thought about
dating in San Francisco.
Now here we are in San Francisco,
at the most famous bridge
that we can afford to film in front of,
the Bay Bridge.
So, we're gonna go and ask some people
what it's like to date in San Francisco,
and hopefully get a date.
I don't know, we'll see what happens.
(bells ring)
Ooh, church bells.
I am here with.
- Uh, Andrew.
- How would you describe
dating in San Francisco?
- Uhh, whole bunch of sex,
not a whole lot of dates.
Well, I'm gay, and,
San Francisco's like playground.
- Sure.
- People coming through all the time.
So everyone just constantly
like looking for somebody else.
So other cities, it's a little calmer,
little more chance for a relationship.
Here it's just fun.
- Any tips for someone
dating just for a few days
in San Francisco?
You can be as honest
and crude as you want.
- Oh, um.
Get on Grindr.
- I made a mental note to get onto Grindr
and we moved on.
My first date was with Mark
at the Comstock Saloon.
Well, thank you for meeting me here.
- Thank you for having me here.
- I was a little nervous for this date.
You didn't grow up here?
- No, I did, well, I
moved here when I was 13.
From Egypt.
- Oh, cool.
And then when he showed up, he
was taller and better looking
than I thought he was going to be.
Which made me even more nervous.
Would you surf if you
were close to the beach?
- Yeah, of course.
I mean I'm comparing it
to the beaches in Egypt.
- Oh yeah, you lived, tell me about that.
- Egypt is beautiful.
Just being at like the pyramids,
or like all these ancient monuments,
you're just like wow.
- Right there, I was actually
looking up pictures of Egypt.
I was not just on my phone.
I just want everyone to know that.
I was not being rude.
He was really nice, we
agreed on most things.
- If that means that I will get--
- We got like a couple drinks, and chats.
The conversation kept going.
It just felt it kept building.
Yeah, fuck it, what is it gonna do?
- We're watching Kate's date.
- I think he's trying to get the butt.
He's been saying yes to everything,
agreeing to everything.
And he got the second drink.
- Um, truth be told,
there wasn't the biggest spark.
It was a good, definitely
a good icebreaker.
I was excited to see what other
dates were going to happen.
Well thank you so much.
This was a delight.
- Kate, the pleasure was all mine.
Take care.
- All right.
Well get home safely.
- Okay, thank you.
Bye bye.
I think one of the reasons
that dating is so hard is that
I'm, I try to be a really good date
before I try to like really
connect with this person.
So I sort of prevent bad dates.
By like being a chameleon
to whoever I'm near.
So my goal for today
is to not to that.
Now some of the things
that I definitely like
about Internet dating
is that I can date in bed.
While I'm bloated.
You think they'll notice
I haven't shaved my legs?
'Cause I didn't.
I also didn't bring a razor.
Also this isn't how I'd like
my hair to look for today.
But you know, I just didn't
bring a straightener.
- The second date was
with Nick, at Marianne's,
a speakeasy style bar.
You had to like know a password to get in.
Very cool, very nice bar.
- Hey, how's it going?
- Good, how are you?
- I'm Nick.
- I'm Kate, nice to meet you.
- Thanks for meeting me here.
- Well, thanks for
coming on a date with me.
- Wow, this place is really fancy.
- What do you like, look for in people?
What's your type?
- I don't think I really have a type,
to be totally honest.
I would pretty much go up to anyone.
(laughs)
I don't think that I'm
like very uncomfortable
around other people,
which is probably a good thing.
But it could also be really
bad if the person's shy.
I'm like, "Hey, how are ya?"
They're like, "No, please, too much!"
- I really appreciate when people call out
that something is awkward,
instead of just plugging
along like it's not awkward.
He was like, "Oh, this is kinda weird."
I was like, "It is weird."
'Cause it is weird to date on camera.
And to date at all.
Just the whole thing's weird.
- I think the date's going really well.
- Would you ever consider
dating someone you work with?
- Yeah, I mean like--
- You would?
- Yeah, I guess.
I think that's like the best
way to meet people, though.
Is like at work, or at some sort of like.
I'm joined a rock climbing gym,
and that's my hope is
to meet someone there.
But it has not happened.
- I joined a kickball league.
- You're not gonna find
anyone in kickball.
- I don't know if you agree.
Would you prefer to have
someone that's like,
"Hey, I haven't grown up yet.
"I'm like still a kid."
but, or would you rather
have someone be like--
- Did you have that on your profile?
- Or it's like, "Hey,
like, I'm a video producer,
"so I'm employed.
"But I'm in touch with
my inner, like, child."
- Got it.
I think in touch with your inner
child is better than saying
I'm still a little kid.
It's just weird, it's a
weird, you gotta be selective
when you throw those words around.
- Can't really put little kid in your
Tinder bio.
That's creepy.
We should totally hang
out if you have time,
and you feel like hanging
out with me again.
If I didn't blow this.
- You blew it.
- HOw'd I do?
- Sorry, but you blew it.
- Gimme like a--
- Please leave, you blew it.
I'm just kidding.
Give you a grade?
- Gimme a grade.
If you were gonna--
- Are you kidding me?
- At the end of your dates,
if you were gonna grade your dates.
But honestly, like hard, hard grading.
- I don't wanna grade you.
- One to ten scale.
- One to ten?
I wanna evaporate.
(laughing) I wanna melt into the wall.
I think you're battin' about a,
an eight?
And now I'm gonna have
to knock you down to six
for asking me to grade you.
- You know, I can always
live with the fact
that I was an eight at some point,
but I think you're a 12 out of ten, so.
- Wow, now I feel like a dick.
Overall, it was a good date.
I had a good time.
- Thanks for having me, Kate.
And hopefully, when you come back to SF,
we can hang out again.
- Yeah, I'll let you know.
- All right, see you later.
- See ya, have fun at work.
That date went, in my mind,
way better than last night.
Last night was cool,
but I felt like I wasn't trying too hard.
This time I was like,
letting it be awkward where
it needed to be awkward.
And he was really nice.
So after the second date,
we decided to go out and
explore the city to see if
it was even a fun city to be in.
And it turns out it is.
What a delight!
What do you guys like
most about San Francisco?
- I love the diverse community.
- Really just wanted to set up
shop and stay there forever.
You guys go on dates?
- Um, not really.
- Not really.
A lot of great Instagram backgrounds here.
Every which way you looked,
lotta color, there was
nice little coffee shop.
Mm, I can talk about it all day.
Lotta hills.
What's it like to date in San Francisco?
- We got handsome men out
here and beautiful women.
Come to San Francisco.
You see my host right here,
she's beautiful too, see?
- Wow this is my favorite
intersection of any intersection
probably ever.
Look at that place is pretty.
I like that.
I wanna go there.
My third date was with
Jake at The Interval.
The Interval was a really great place.
Loved it.
Very nice decor.
Great staff.
Very good drinks.
The date was.
Well, you'll see.
Hello.
- Hi, Kate.
- Nice to see you.
- Nice to see you, absolutely.
- Welcome, have you been here before?
- I have not, it's my first time.
- Interesting.
I feel like we should get a drink first.
- That's a great idea.
- Okay, what do you drink?
- I will do an old fashioned.
- Aha!
Cheers.
- So, I have my own company.
And just decided to bring it out here.
- Ooh, look, there's a
bug on the, this thing.
See it?
It's like a little mosquito right there.
- That's one of my favorite
things about Houston.
- Killing bugs.
- Is the Houston bird is a mosquito.
- Really?
- You're not gonna laugh at that, c'mon.
- (laughs) Sorry.
- C'mon!
- Sorry.
You know, sometimes you
just don't connect at all?
With someone, like at all?
So have you been on
Internet dating for a while?
- This is my first Internet date actually.
- Really?
- Yeah, I'm lying.
You're so gullible!
(laughing)
- You're right, I am gullible.
- This is not going well.
- This dude sucks.
- So I recently found out
that there are five pictures
you could use on your
online dating profile
that will help you get matches.
It is, you doing something active.
You hanging out with friends
to prove that you have friends.
You with an animal, usually a dog.
You dressed fancy.
And then one picture of you
dancing with either your mom
or your grandma, something like that.
This guy had four out
of those five pictures.
And the dog wasn't his.
Now what was your worst date?
- Worst date.
Was one time, I went out with this girl
that was working for BuzzFeed.
Nah, I'm just kidding.
- Got it.
Fair.
- Sometimes you do run into people that
are only seeing you just because
they know that you have
more money than them.
And they'd like for you to
buy everything for them.
Ran into one of those recently.
Probably like a few weeks ago.
And uh, yeah,
she was telling me how
she wanted a sugar daddy.
And how, and I told her too, I was like,
"Well, is that all you have to offer?
Is just a pretty face?"
- I bet that didn't end too well.
- I mean, that's not what I'm looking for,
so I'm not trying to pick up a sugar baby.
- How much more time do we
have to be here before cleanup?
- What time is it?
- It is 9:17.
We do not have time for one more drink.
Needless to say, there wasn't
gonna be a second date.
One, because I don't
live in San Francisco.
And two, because we did
not hit it off at all.
And I don't feel bad saying that.
Normally, I would.
But I don't feel bad saying
that because he did in fact
unmatch me real soon after the date.
After that date, we decided
to go to a local bar
to see if I could flirt
with people in person.
This was my nightmare.
I'm here at the Make-Out Room.
I'm gonna go in and
begrudgingly flirt with young, hip people
and see if I can't find me some dick.
Going out in a different
city and flirting is,
I think easier than flirting
in the place where you live,
because you can vacation flirt.
Which is be the best
possible version of yourself
without ever having to
back it up longterm.
However, it was like a Tuesday night,
and they weren't biting, let me tell ya.
Cheers, no one!
- It did not go as expected.
Turns out, I actually
might be better online
than I am in person.
Fine.
Know your strengths!
Yeah.
I'm losing faith.
I'm gonna be alone.
Whatever, it's easier.
So my fourth date was
with Riad at the aquarium.
Very fun location.
He was on uh,
Shark Tank.
And we went to the aquarium.
That was not on purpose.
It just so happened that that
was the time he was free.
It's the same day that
we're going to the aquarium.
Hello.
- How's it going?
- [Katy] Good, how are you?
- Good.
- [Katy] Thank you for coming.
Glad you found the place.
- Yeah, of course, of course.
Good to see you.
- You, too.
- All right.
All right, ready to go into the aquarium?
- Yeah, I wanna see some fish.
Sushi, you know, that kinda stuff.
- Gross.
Pretty cool.
- What's your favorite fish to eat?
- I think tuna's my favorite--
- Tuna.
Spicy tuna?
- Yeah.
- Okay, good deal.
- What's yours?
- Spicy tuna's up there.
- Up there?
What's your fave?
- Shrimp tempura.
- Do you date often?
- Dating, yeah.
Nothing really in the works.
- Yeah?
- Yeah.
It's kinda more of a secondary thing.
- Got it.
- It's pretty big.
- Super big.
- Oh it's a type of shark, maybe.
Look at the fins.
- Do you wanna see what it's
like to be in a fish tank?
- Yeah, lemme get my head in there.
- [Katy] Looks cool,
you look really small.
- I do.
I feel small.
- Look cool, do you want a picture?
He's gone.
He had a, wasn't the best date.
We didn't really mesh.
Yeah, we were just on like
two different planes really.
Um.
Gotta love 'em, you know?
- So what's like an ideal date for you?
Something to break the ice like this?
And then get some food or drinks?
- I think ideally it
wouldn't be with a camera.
- [Woman] They're actually in their own
separate family of the
very permanent fish,
been around 200 million
years, haven't changed much.
- I've been in a shark tank before.
(laughs)
- He was on Shark Tank.
- A literal.
- [Woman] Really? Oh nice.
- Not a real.
That was just a bad joke.
I'm really good at bad jokes.
- Oh, the seagulls are my favorite.
- Until they shit on you.
- No I love, well I mean, yeah sure.
Hear it's good luck.
Ooh, what's that?
- What was what?
- Do you see that thing floating?
- [Riad] It might be trash.
- True, true, might be.
- Looks like maybe a
water bottle or something.
- Anywho, well, this was fun.
Thank you.
- Yeah, it was fun.
Glad we saw the fish.
- Yeah, that was fun, good date.
- Yeah, it was pretty good.
- What do you think?
- He was okay.
- He talked a lot about himself,
and didn't really follow
through on conversations.
It was kinda awkward.
- Okay, so we're on the way back.
Back to LA.
And this is how I would
rate San Francisco.
Number of matches, 245.
How expensive was it?
It was very expensive.
Is it a good place to be single?
Yeah, if you have a lotta money.
San Francisco was great.
It wasn't perfect.
I went on more dates in three days
than I have in the past three months, so.
I learned a lot about how I
present myself physically.
I'm a little bit of a huncher, slouch.
Need to sit up, stand up straight.
I close myself off a whole lot.
And um, I make rough faces.
So uh, where should we go next?
Maybe Seattle?
I was told Nashville.
I was also told Butte, Montana.
I'm really, you know what?
This point, I'm fielding no offers.
So you guys just, you let me know.
Ah, got hair in my
mouth, in that last bit.
Thanks for watching.
(laughs)